from its feverish inspiration to strange
early casting discussions to an iconic
shot that almost got the crew in trouble
with the law here are a few facts you
might not have known about the making of
the Terminator some films begin with the
story while others begin with an image
in the case of the Terminator it began
with a literal fever dream after an
awful experience filming piranhas -
writer director James Cameron retreated
to Rome to recover he told Entertainment
Weekly nightmares are a business asset
that's the way I look at it I was sick I
was broke I had a high fever and I had a
dream about this metal death figure
coming out of a fire and the implication
was that it had been stripped of its
skin by the fire and exposed for what it
really was when I have some particularly
vivid image I'll draw it or I'll write
some notes and that goes on to this day
Cameron sketched his fever vision and
eventually showed the images to young
producer Gale and heard the Terminator
was born with the idea set in their
minds Cameron and Hurd elaborated on the
film's script then began to shop at
around two studios as a low-budget
guerilla style film the Cameron would
direct and Hurd would produce to keep
costs low they decided to have Lance
Henriksen play The Terminator
but when Orion Pictures came on board
with financing they had a much crazier
idea Oh Jay Simpson Cameron said no to
that idea but reluctantly agreed to take
a meeting with Orion head Mike Medavoy
stop choice to play the heroic time
traveler Kyle Reese met a voice choice
Conan the Barbarian star Arnold
Schwarzenegger
Cameron was skeptical but came away
impressed by Schwarzenegger zai Diaz for
the character of the Terminator instead
of offering him the role of Reese
Cameron offered Schwarzenegger the role
of terminator Schwarzenegger initially
feared playing the villain would hurt
his leading man image but Cameron won
him over
Schwarzenegger told Entertainment Weekly
but Cameron said that he'd shoot it in
such a way that all the evil stuff that
I do will be totally excused by
audiences because I'm a cool machine and
so cool that some of the people will
cheer shorts and Egger took the role he
would prove to be the best decision of
his career he wasn't the only second
pick in the film though with
Schwarzenegger off the board numerous
stars were considered for the role of
Rhys including everyone from Mel Gibson
and Kurt Russell to Bruce Springsteen
Superman star Christopher Reeve declined
a million-dollar offer to play the role
but perhaps the strangest star to pass
on the film was the musicians sting
after being offered a cool $350,000 to
play the role sting ultimately passed
because of prior obligations including a
role in the epic science fiction flop
dune opening the door for Michael Biehn
who would team with Cameron again for
aliens in 1986 and the abyss in 1989
even some of the talent behind the
scenes were second choices Cameron and
Hurd originally wanted legendary makeup
artist Dick Smith to design the
terminators look he said no but pointed
them towards another rising star in the
business Stan Winston who would go on to
win four Academy Awards for his effects
work including two for Terminator 2
though she would go on to become an
action badass in subsequent films in the
first Terminator movie Sarah Connor
spends the whole movie running away and
that was a problem for star Linda
Hamilton because just before shooting
she broke her ankle tearing some
ligaments - just for good measure to
make things easier on Hamilton
urghhh shuffled the production schedule
around so that many of the scenes that
involve running were shot near the end
of principal photography but it was
still far from easy Hurd told
Entertainment Weekly she had to run
throughout the movie and it was mostly
Linda by the way
on a broken ankle if it had to be
wrapped every day the Terminator
franchise has endured for more than
three decades and through it all one
line has remained a signature not just
for the franchise but for Schwarzenegger
as a major action star I'll be back
ironically Schwarzenegger tried to
change the line I couldn't pronounce
really well this aisle so I just
considered that Jim can miniatures just
say I will be back
Cameron refused to budge this is none
Isis look I didn't tell you how to act
don't tell me how to write I wrote the
line I'll be back Cameron shot several
takes of the scene and had
Schwarzenegger deliver the same line a
different way each time then picked the
best take almost immediately after the
film was released fans were approaching
Schwarzenegger on the street to ask him
to repeat it Cameron and Hurd shot the
film guerilla style filming mini scenes
without location permits and that almost
got the production in hot water with the
law during the filming of the final
scene when a cop crashed the party Hurd
told Entertainment Weekly he said I need
to see your permit for filming here we
didn't have one we said oh officer were
making a UCLA student film we didn't
know you needed permits and he said okay
you're fine just take the camera off the
road I don't know if that cop ever
figured it out wherever he is we thanked
him for not shutting us down
in the summer of 1984 as the Terminator
was nearing completion Cameron took a
rough cut to show the bosses at Orion
they were less than impressed with
Cameron calling the screening quote
disastrous Byrd told Entertainment
Weekly they had such little faith in the
movie that they didn't want to screen it
for critics the head of marketing almost
said as much and if you were Orion and
you had Amadeus which they had released
five weeks before and which did go on to
win Best Picture
well I can imagine them saying Amadeus
The Terminator which one doesn't fit I
can't blame them now but at the time I
was devastated when they didn't like it
in the terminators closing credits
there's one credit that may seem odd to
viewers not familiar with how it came
about
it reads acknowledgment to the works of
Harlan Ellison Ellison of course was a
legendary science fiction author who is
almost as legendary for being hint
Kuras so when he discovered the
similarities between the Terminator and
to Ellison stories for the 60s TV series
Outer Limits soldier and demon with a
glass hand he contacted his lawyers
we've been altered to look like humans
it was necessary to come back into time
and find you what do you want with me
you're the last hope of earth Cameron
publicly denied ripping off Ellison
stories but Ellison reached a settlement
out of court with the studio that
included both money and that credit
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]